Hello everyone
I was just browsing the Internet as I usually do and I came across a photo of Carlson's sister Ingrid
On Twitter and whenever I see a photo of her. I think to myself
So that's what Magnus would look like with long hair as they are incredibly similar
Which you can see from the photo here
So then I thought I know Carlson has three sisters
But I never knew if any of them played chess so I checked the database at chess
Gamescom it seems both the Ingrid and Ellen play chess Ingrid is rated around 1600
Although she doesn't play anymore since the database only covers games from
2007 to 2010 so I don't think she's an active player and Ellen is the rate at the
around
So since no YouTube channel ever showed a game by Ingrid Carson died I decided to show one
it was played in 2010 it is the
Gibraltar Open tournament, and she has the white pieces against Nadia Reci from Switzerland
So let's see this game
e4
e5 Knight to f3
d6
the Philidor defense
We have d4 and
in this position
I'm sure you'll remember Bishop to b -- Bishop to g4 is the Opera House move one of the
most criticized moves in chess history
So in the game we have e captures on d4 which isn't a mistake, but this is generally something. You don't want to do ever
Because by capturing you allow Knight captures on d5 and you only allow the white to improve the position of his night
He was on f3 now. He's closer to the center, and it's a it's much much nicer square for the knight
Better in this position then capturing on d4 would be something like
Knight to d7 or Knight to f6 and continuing the game
You know it's the best to always follow that all saying to take is a mistake if you don't gain anything by capturing don't capture
But okay in the game
We have e captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 and Knight to f6 developing a piece with a tempo attacking the e4 pawn
Knight to c3 defending, bishop to e7 preparing to Castle Bishop to e2 also preparing to castle
Nadia castles Bishop to e3 now Bishop to e6 and
Ingrid castles Queen to d7 is played and
Here Ingrid captures the Bishop Knight captures on e6 which again isn't isn't a mistake or anything
You know you grabbed a bishop with a Knight, Now you have the bishop prepare white still has a very comfortable game
But maybe something other than capturing the bishop an interesting line would be f4
now threatening of course f5 to
Trap this bishop on e6 and after something like Bishop to g4
Push e5 and after Bishop captures Bishop Queen captures Bishop
D captures on e5 f captures on e5 and Knight to d5
White has this interesting idea of rook captures on f7 if you capture the rook you get e6
The knight is protecting the pawn on e6 and after something like Knight captures on
c3 e captures on f7 would check King captures and B captures on c3
White would have a very comfortable game here the queen is coming to c4 which with great tempo the rook is coming to f1
This would be this would be great for white
But okay in the game after Queen d7 Knight captures and e6 was played and now
It does seem more appropriate to capture with the Queen. You don't want to mess up the defense of your King
But Nadia plays f Captures on e6 and okay you do now get another central pawn you open up
the F file for your rook, but it might have been better to capture with Queen captures on  e6
now Ingrid plays f4
We have E. 5 and f5
Here Knight to c6 Bishop to f3
adding more protection d4 pawn
So Knight to d5 can be played so this is like a preparation move
a6 and now G for preparing G v
H6 was played and now Knight to d5
Here you definitely want to capture this knight on d5 is it's an extremely powerful piece
You don't want to allow a knight captures on e7 so something like knight captures on d5 Queen captures on d5 with check
King h7 and
It's a much more comfortable position for white, but but black can hold this
but after Knight to d5 and Nadia decided to go for
for for an ambitious move Knight to h7
Probably preparing something like Bishop to g5 to exchange the dark square bishop
But of course this isn't allowed Knight captures on e7 with Check Queen captures on e7 and c3
Controlling that Knight, so the knight can't really jump into play
king to h8
Probably probably getting the king out of this
Diagonal so the Queen can to jump to d5 with tempo, maybe if this Knight moves the b7 pawn would be vulnerable
And maybe would ideas of rook to g8 who knows
21 now preparing Queen to g3
Knight the d8 trying to get the night to help out with the defense of the king
H4 now and h4 is the strongest move recommended by the engine
Knights to f7
But already this Knight to f7 move is looking for trouble you have a knight on f7 and you have a night on h7
This pawn is coming coming to g6
Queen to g3
Now preparing g5
King to g8 and this is this is a weird move. I don't really
understand this move
Maybe making room for the night an h-shaped, but but who knows maybe
Maybe a better move here for black wouldn't be something like rook the g8 to
Maybe try and open up the position with the g6 and capture on f5 but but okay
Queen to rook earth King today, it was played
And now King to h1 by Ingrid preparing the work to come to the G file
And here c5 was played and the C file doesn't really stop any of White's plans on the King side
a better choice would be something like
d 5 the white is attacking and King said you don't want to break open the center and
after something like rook a to d1 and rook a to d8
If he captor son d5 then Knight to d6
Preparing the pawn pawn to e4 move and maybe black would get some counter play
white is better of course but
Definitely better than this c5 move so rook to g1
Adding more pressure to the G file and Queen to f6 now
And this is this is of course the mistake that cost Nadia the game
Here probably was was the last tried to go for something like d5
And after g5h captures h captures and after Knight to d6
black would have a very very hard game after f6
But black is falling apart here, so neither didn't go for this slightly better defense after rook to g1 she played the Queen to f6
And this allows the immediate the g5
This now comes with a temple on the Queen so after H captures and g5 + H captures on g5
in this position neither resigned the game
As of course as I mentioned that night to f7 was looking for trouble after Queen to e7
G6 would have been played and one of the Knights is is going down with check
So this never happened after
this HK % g5
Neither resigned the game and Ingrid won this
this nice game in 23 moves
So yeah like I said
No channel ever show the game by a cost and sister so so I decided to show one and if any of you are interested
Like I said an idea of no
Ellen is a higher rated around
1950 so if any of you feel like
investigating chess games comm
If you can find an interesting game by Ellen feel free to suggest and I will show that one as well
So that's the game I do. Hope you enjoyed it
And I am getting fairly close
to fifty fifty thousand subscribers
I will definitely make make some kind of an interesting stream on Saturday
And maybe I will try to prepare a chess quiz as a lot of you have been asking for a chess quiz
So I'm planning a tournament
Also, if I will be able to prepare a chess quiz in a way for it to work because last time we did has some
problems because some
Some people have faster internet, so they get they get the question sooner than than the other players. I have no idea
how this happens it's just that it just does but it it's
the guy who won the quiz was actually
Tom from Slovenia, and he actually won a lot of chess quizzes
So I don't think the problem was really in his internet connection
He really he said he knew all the questions except two, but you know there weren't pretty easy questions
So yeah, I just wanted you to know that and I am
seriously taking suggestions on what to do for the giveaway as you know it would be okay to do a nice giveaway for the
50,000 subscribers milestone
So if you have any any suggestions feel free to share in the comment section
So yeah, I would like to thank John Carter for your contribution to my channel
Thank you a lot - really appreciate it as usual you can check two of my previous videos here
Thank you all for watching, and I will see you soon